Американські "Джавеліни" й британські NLAW в руках українських військових.
Ці ракети гарантовано знищують танки супротивника.
Винищувачі й бомбардувальники атакують колону ворожих танків.
Протягом лютого такі навчання військових відбуваються на десятках полігонів України.
До 2014 року уявити такі маневри ЗСУ було складно.
Нині українська армія - зовсім інша.
До 2013 року Україна позбавилася ядерного арсеналу, ушестеро скоротила кількісний склад збройних сил.
Після окупації Криму - втратила майже весь флот.
Нині українське військо на 22-му місці серед найпотужніших армій світу за даними Global Firepower Index.
На сьогодні збройні сили України оснащені.
Так, у нас є ще потреби.
Разом з тим ви бачите, що західні країни зараз дуже інтенсивно нам допомагають.
За осінь і ось цю частину зими тільки із Сполучених Штатів ми отримали 17 літаків боєприпасів, зброї, амуніції.
А ще нам допомагає Канада, Великобританія, Естонія, Латвія, Литва і ще цілий ряд країн.
Утім чи достатньо власних потужностей і допомоги Заходу, аби стримати другу армію світу - російську?
Безумовно, чисельно дещо і якісно перевага противника нами врахована.
Безумовно, ми не зможемо на всіх напрямках дати адекватну відповідь.
Але ми знаємо більш загрозливі напрямки, ми готові до зосередження основних зусиль на тих напрямках,
де противник буде більш активно діяти. Воєнне мистецтво ще ніхто не відміняв.
Далеко не вся інформація про боєздатність армії - відкрита.
Але військові експерти погоджуються: піхота, протитанкові комплекси, артилерія, вогнемети, міномети, танки -
це сильна сторона української армії.
Тоді як "тонких" місць теж вистачає.
У нас є такі точки болю - це повітряні сили, з зенітними ракетними військами, з авіацією
і ВМС, які, на жаль, в більшості не здатні виконувати бойових завдань в морі.
У нас є декілька десятків літаків, в першу чергу винищувачів МіГ-29, Су-27,
бомбардувальників Су-24М, штурмовиків Су-25, які при вмілій тактиці застосування
можуть створювати певні проблеми по застосуванню "Воздушно-космических войск".
Але йдеться не про повноцінні повітряні бої.
На жаль, росіяни отримали понад 600 нових літаків з 14-го року - нових і модернізованих.
І це повністю перекриває наш потенціал.
Нині чисельність української армії - 250 тисяч осіб.
У 2022 році почалося створення Сил тероборони - окремого роду військ.
Це вже додало 11 тисяч людей, кажуть в Міноборони.
За указом президента, ЗСУ хочуть збільшити ще на 100 тисяч осіб.
Утім, експерти сумніваються, що оборонного бюджету на це вистачить.
Попри те, що починаючи з 2014-го, він щороку зростає.
Просте збільшення на 100 тисяч людей без відповідного збільшення фінансування не дасть нічого.
Ви тільки розмажете і так невеликий бюджет на ще більшу кількість людей.
Відповідно, якість Збройних сил впаде, скажемо так.
Крім того, у владі планують до 2024 року створити професійну армію.
Скасувати призов, запровадити коротку інтенсивну підготовку, збільшити зарплати військовим.
Це й досі болюче питання. Понад 65 відсотків військовослужбовців звільняються після першого контракту.
Насамперед через низькі зарплати.
На передовій завдяки надбавкам виплати можуть складати 20-30 тисяч гривень.
У звичайній військовій частині солдат отримує в середньому 10 тисяч гривень.
Ми повинні створити систему стимулювання, розумієте.
Без цієї системи просування… Набір 100 тисяч планують набрати - ми не зможемо.
Пропонують нам контракт на 10 років, а що взамін?
Ми не маємо військового омбудсмена, який є в Німеччині.
Ми не маємо стимулів для військовослужбовців, особливо рядового сержантського складу.
І все ж армія вже стала привабливішою.
ЗСУ очолюють рейтинг довіри українців.
Та й мотивація у військових нині набагато вища, ніж вісім років тому.
Найкраще, що сьогодні в збройних силах є, це саме солдат.
Не чиновник, підкреслюю це слово, а солдат.
Питання навіть не в досвіді, питання в людях.
Питання в людях, які здатні цей досвід взяти, які при зневазі з боку чиновників, з боку оборонно-промислового комплексу.
Порівняння російської та української армії - не на користь ЗСУ.
Це дані Global Firepower Index. Кількісний склад, бюджет і техніка у РФ в рази більші.
Рівні показники лише в одному пункті - по 250 тисяч резервістів.
Утім тут не врахували ще один критерій - мотивацію українських військових.
І дані соціологів: практично кожен другий українець готовий захищати батьківщину зі зброєю в руках.